it's a little cold in here it's actually
great you actually love this because
then you're not gonna sweat this is like
a David Letterman studio yeah okay I
think of it in a positive way like that
but um I was gonna make a joke but one
of the things that I really respect
about your filmmaking and something that
I think is fantastic is these the movies
you made the really make you feel like
you're there it captures like a time in
a place talked a little bit about doing
that in your films and why that's so
important to you
I don't I don't know I love being
transported to the Past when it when I
read books and watch films and so I try
to do the same thing for an audience I
think you know the more attention to
detail the the the making sure the
buttons and floorboards are accurate
never mind the the Steamship that takes
them to and from the island about every
little detail it creates it creates an
atmosphere and at the silly
black-and-white format with the antique
lenses and that we're using these help
create an atmosphere and and when you
have this atmosphere and this world that
you can believe in then you can believe
in mermaids and sea monsters a little
more among other things Lily um one of
the things is I loved the use of the old
cameras and the lenses and I mean for me
as a cinephile
it was awesome how challenging was it to
locate these cameras to get these lenses
and to actually like have the financers
be like yeah that's cool you can do this
once once the financers were on board
shooting black and white and black and
white 35-millimeter negative as in
there's no color version of this movie
in any way possible then it was sort of
like okay if you want to go crawl around
with a flashlight in the back of the pan
of vision closets and find old dusty
lenses that no one's touched since the
1930s we were over it at this point so
so so that that part of it the lenses
nobody minded you know but but it was
the format that was a little bit more
challenging but again once once once the
financier and distributor were on board
they were they were incredibly
supportive and gave me and my
collaborators great
freedom Hey I mean clearly because this
is not normal yeah I asked this of every
filmmaker how long was your first cut
compared to the finished film not much
longer
I'm Jaron and I do not shoot coverage we
just don't we don't it's not how we our
minds work that you know the first cut
of my first feature the the which was 97
minutes and the final version was 92 or
93 and with this film the first cut was
2 hours and 7 minutes and the final
version was it's an hour 50 oh well yeah
so it's really close um I'm gonna run
out of time with you in a second and I
am so excited that you basically your
next film has sort of been announced
oh my you know it was leaked not
announced but I might be able to talk
about it depending on what your question
is well I want to know because you've
been you've been you've done such a good
job at capturing the time in a place how
are you planning have you already
started thinking about how am I gonna
make the 10th century with Vikings
authentic and real on screen I mean I've
been thinking about it for over two
years so you know let's let's hope that
it works out are you planning on
shooting it in black and white is it
going to be color have you thought that
far ahead
the movie is too expensive to be black
and white even if I wanted it to be and
and because much of the film takes place
in Iceland it's got good color is there
it's like another planet
indeed my last thing for you it's
remembered that the skarsgård brothers
could be in it and playing Vikings no
less right how was it tough to convince
them to do this or were they all in
nobody's deals are done yet but you know
I you know whatever I like hanging out
with people who couldn't beat me up I
don't know oh well then I'll just say
this for you I'm tremendously looking
forward to whatever ends up being next
and I commend you on making this I
really hope everyone comes out for it